hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
heute gibt es gleich drei rezepte in
einem und zwar stelle ich euch heute
meine drei lieblings dressings für
salate vor
ihr könnt die alle drei wirklich gut
zubereiten und dann einfach im
kühlschrank lagern und euch jeden tag
bedienen
die salate kann man auch ganz gut
vorbereiten das heißt erst anfang der
woche einmal kurzarbeit und können dann
die restliche woche immer alles aus dem
kühlschrank rausnehmen
ich fange jetzt direkt an mit dem honig
senf dressing und zeigt was sich da an
zutaten benötige und zwar nämlich hier
direkt eine knoblauch knolle und die
können das entweder klein pressen oder
schneiden ich zurück die einfach so ein
bisschen und da geht es ab 15
zum knoblauch kommt jetzt noch 20
esslöffel rapsöl
das ist auch eine ganz große menge zu
wirklich schon so ein wochen vorrat
da kommen jetzt noch zehn esslöffel
weißweinessig mit dazu und der moral hat
jetzt extra die chinesische
knoblauchzehe geholt weil material dazu
stinkt ja natürlich freunde haben möchte
dann für die schüsse fünf esslöffel
honig des krieges schon nach hause
da kommen jetzt noch fünf teelöffel
mittel scharfer senf dazu
und dann noch etwa 1 bis zwei teelöffel
salles ich gebe immer erst ein bisschen
weg herein und schmeckt dann einfach
noch mal ab und noch bis 1 dazu und
jetzt wird alles gut miteinander
verrührt
wer möchte kann jetzt hier noch frische
kräuter mit dazu geben aber im prinzip
ist es 30 soll es fertig kann auch gut
durchziehen und die knoblauchzehe die
gibt dann immer mehr geschmack ab das
nächste treffen ist ein balsamico
dressing und dafür nämlich balsamico
essig und zwar fünf esslöffel
das hört die zuschauer du machst ja
immer den löwen ganz folgen genau als
ich mache den löffel nicht ganz voll
und dann kann so ein bisschen weiter
fließen und dann ist es immer so ein
voller esslöffel als nächstes kam auch
fünf esslöffel balsamico creme mit rein
und es ist so eine etwas festere
als nächstes gehe ich zehn esslöffel
olivenöl mit rein und da muss ich das
ganze nur noch mit salz und pfeffer und
etwas zucker würzen
also ein teelöffel salz warum zucker bis
100 das ganze ganz gut ab vor allem
nimmt bisschen die säure wenn ich kein
zucker dann hat dann schmeckt sie auch
nicht dann sagst du immer das ist sauer
bei sami khedira wenn es zu soll ich
nicht populär magie sein ja beim broker
fast und das letzte dressing ist ein
joghurt dressing und staffel nehme ich
jetzt joghurt der hat jetzt 35 prozent
anteil
und da nehme ich jetzt 300 milliliter
also es passt ganz gut mit einem
messbecher
dann gebe ich 80 milliliter jeweils
weißwein essig und öl mit dazu
ich bin dann mag ich auch packen
ja ich darf jetzt kommt ein teelöffel
zucker mit rein und ein teelöffel salz
und auf etwas pfeffer und da kommen auch
noch vier teelöffel senf und rennen
machen
mach doch was los ich gucke zu
die drei adressen ist jetzt fertig und
wir machen es immer ganz gerne so dass
wir uns ein salatbuffet machen und jeder
kann sich dann einfach nehmen was er
möchte
deswegen habe ich jetzt hier schon mal
salat vorbereitet und werde jetzt das
ganze gemüse erst mal klein schneiden
jetzt auf einmal zu kriegen
17 serie planen gestalten
beim granatapfel mache ich es immer so
dass ich eben einmal rundherum ein
ritter aber nicht komplett durchschneide
dann sehe ich ihn mit den händen
auseinander und dann nehme ich einen
werkzeug ich nehme jetzt ganz gerne die
zitrus presse dies nämlich schön fest
und schwer
und dann hab ich einfach drauf und so
bekommt man die ganz leicht da raus
die salate sind jetzt fertig vorbereitet
und murat hat sich jetzt natürlich noch
ein steak gewünscht kein zutritt aber
ein steak und das verrate ich ihnen
jetzt noch an und dann zeige ich euch
wie wir das hier alles gleich servieren
habt ihr jetzt von jeder seite etwa eine
minute angebraten ganz scharf und jetzt
gebe ich sie noch mal für etwa vier bis
fünf minuten bei 80 grad in den ofen
so sieht es jetzt bei uns aus und zwar
brauche ich hier immer ganz gerne so
einem buffet auf man kann sich jeder das
nehmen was er möchte und was jemand
besten schmeckt und ich finde es immer
ganz praktisch wenn man diese dressings
eben schon vorbereitet hat gerade am
abend wenn man vielleicht von der arbeit
kommt und nicht mehr so gut kochen
möchte dann kann man es immer ganz
schnell zubereiten und wenn ihr gerne
mehr solche schnelle rezepte sehen
möchtet dann schreibt mir die kommentare
ich bin auf jeden fall sehr praktisch
und sehr alltagstauglich und dann
wünsche ich euch schon mal ganz viel
spaß beim nachmachen und vielleicht
könnt ihr mir schreiben welches dieser
drei dressings euer lieblings dressing
ist also bei mir wechselt sich
eigentlich immer ab aber ich glaube
jetzt mache ich mir ganz bunt gemischten
salat und hund sind also bis zum
nächsten mal